sir Anish Kapoor one of the world's most
visible and influential artists and I'm
so pleased to sit here with you in front
of such a great audience it's true it's
a world premiere not happening here in
our conversation but just outside of
this auditorium and truth is the theme
of this entire conference one can be
true to oneself perhaps one can be true
to a material as a sculptor or true to a
new technology and what would it be to
be true to this new relatively unknown
territory of virtual reality maybe you
can tell us a little bit about your new
experiment after our previous speaker
it's hard to reflect on the relative
frivolous frivolity of such questions
however they do all go to the same
fundamental questions about how we
perceive our world the virtual virtual
reality is rather interesting at one
level virtual we can do we have a sense
of what that might means reality is more
complicated so working with new
technology throws one immediately into
this question what I've discovered is
that it's sophisticated but not
sophisticated enough that to make
reality it's full of such immense
subtlety that one has struggles to hold
it's its myriad forms let's say we can
all get a glimpse of the piece outside I
did already
yeah maybe you can just tell us what it
is journey well yeah so we started a god
of a kind and then of course things have
things like this this image here
and one kind of falls through one of the
things I've discovered about this medium
is that it's very good at vertigo so the
propensity to fall is is immense and of
course the vertiginous and the sublime
are very close to each other this idea
of a poetic kind of falling in
especially when its darkness
I think our previous speaker was
speaking about a certain kind of
darkness and it's that darkness that I
think I'm after this sense that whatever
rational apparently rational we can
bring to to our understanding of things
we are always struggling with ghosts so
to describe the piece again you you the
world shatters in whatever way and then
you fall into a vertigo that is purports
to be the inside of your body so it's a
kind of inversion of the self falling
into yourself and then it goes you'll
see you can't help in in in in virtual
processes you can't help but have a
narrative sequence but it's not really
like a feel no it's more like a space
well that's the difficulty is how to
avoid it being like a film because film
word has explored some of these
questions but how to you know have it be
in a condition a singularity rather than
an elaborate journey process your
journey narrative journey in other words
yeah and there's a dialogue between the
arts and science and I'm so pleased that
you're here because you materialize that
dialogue right now there's also a
dialogue between artistic possibilities
and new technologies and it's no
exaggeration that the entire field of
art changed when film appeared
photography appeared a few decades later
some decades later virtual or digital
possibilities the Internet do you think
that VR AR all these digital
possibilities do they represent a
revolution of that magnitude really hard
to say I mean I feel we are as
architects were 15 years ago at the
beginning of a process of manipulating
architects could manipulate form
virtually and it led to certain kind of
form architectural II I mean and we are
that technology has moved on massively
so that in fact you can make all kinds
of virtual real form now it's buildable
what's in the virtual world is now
buildable in architecture virtual
reality I think is still still that it's
a kind of infancy we're having quite it
isn't sophisticated enough record it to
be to be able to you know go where does
one wanted to go I mean eventually I've
identified a certain kind of darkness so
a certain kind of vertigo a certain kind
of poetic condition so how do you use
them at medium in order to to to go
there is the medium sophisticated enough
does it represent to answer your
question more specifically another
version of a new window unseeing and
another version of the world it does
potentially and it has potential to be
every bit as big as photography I think
but it's full of full of issues at the
moment technical issues weirdly which
photography didn't present you know the
wonderful thing about photography is
that it's immediate you actually you can
take a piece of photographic paper
expose it to the light or cover it
slightly and there you have an image
processing you have an image this is
much much more complicated I mean you're
one of the very first major artists if I
may
who tried this new medium and then to me
knowing relatively little about this new
technology
it seems meaningful and I'll tell you
why that many here I think have seen sir
honest art and there are mysterious
spaces but one doesn't really know it's
not illusionism but there's there there
are these places where one doesn't know
if it's a velvet surface or if it's a
cavity academe it's a hidden space hein
hiding somewhere and it's as if you were
already in virtual reality before this
technology actually materialized and I I
put a question on more precisely do you
think and you don't only have to talk
about yourself but do you think that art
has a kind of prophetic capacity I'm you
know this sounds very romantic and
old-fashioned but but you know I heard a
talk recently where someone said that
Emily Bronte's Wuthering Heights the
novel was actually already a film
although their film didn't exist yet but
she had cinematic ideas and I have a
little bit the feeling that some of your
work has virtual reality effects before
their technology happened this is a
complicated question but it is but i but
I do believe that one of the things I've
been concerned with over the years is a
relationship between materiality and non
materiality so two dimensional space and
three dimensional space or four
dimensional space if we if we like what
that has led me to one part of it is the
absence of the object so that's one
thing the other is hyper materiality let
us say something's looking for
conditions of material there are more
material than material now it's a weird
idea but I do believe it exists I'm
special I don't know everything in this
group of works sort of being sharing I
don't think Spencer the other works that
I'd feel there is something about more
material than material
virtual world offers that as a
possibility because it's all happening
in your head it isn't real or well it
isn't real at all and since it's all
happening in there there is this sense
that it's it's got a hyper quality even
though the reality is abstracted so it's
good it's certain it does mist for
example like no other mist it's not very
good at a face though so there are
things that it can do abstract or
relatively abstract conditions it does
color incredibly so you can be immersed
in a in a in a color scene beautifully
so there are things that it does very
very very well and can have this
visceral effect and that's why I've
singled out um vertigo because it's
visceral physical I mean your art is to
a certain extent based on knowledge
scientific knowledge explorations in
scientific I don't know if it's the
right word but you're an expert in human
perception and in certain light and
darkness phenomena pigments that absorb
light very specialized knowledge and all
having to do with I would think human
perception there's a something to
explore there but also a limitation in
virtual reality it seems there is no
limitation except the technology I think
this is a virtual piece called ascension
well yes sort of I've tried to make an
object out of smoke by spinning the air
in a room it kind of becomes an object
so nothing making something it's one of
those one of those kind of possibilities
technology is the only limitation really
our ability to see I think is has to be
the other as they poetic it's a poetic
limitation we can do it I believe
technologically if we can see it and
that is the curious
chicken and egg thing a bit of one does
a bit of the other and this thing
between the two it's it is extraordinary
that the actual making of the work also
moves the technology along because it
has to because the the work demands a
certain sophistication or otherwise in
the direction and pushes the pushes the
technology that's the process so it'll
take a while you emphasize that it's
poetry poetics that is your field rather
than the search for truth and yet I know
a little bit about how you work in a
very sophisticated the Atelier studio
with the people supporting you and would
you say that that the artist studio or
your artists studio is a bit like a
laboratory or in kind of where it's
about poetics rather than the out search
for ultimate truth I think it is a
search for also the truth believe it or
not and it is like a laboratory I mean
but the the experiments are curiously
not haphazard one returns again and
again to the same psychic conditions
without realizing you think you do
something completely different and then
you're back in the same little little
furrow
one hopes that it's deep enough the work
is to not have five great creative years
but to actually keep that process alive
even if it is in a certain area keep it
going what does it mean being an artist
for a short period of time easy it's the
long term that really counts this this
[Music]
continued belief that somewhere one has
to almost remove one's own sense of I've
said before is having something to say
you know one sense of get yourself out
of the way then maybe it can happen
I'm so interested in this dialogue
between the art world and the artistic
disciplines and science therefore I'm
really happy you're here with us and
it's interesting when you say virtually
see see reality is difficult so maybe
you've invented a new genre of being
virtual and real reality that be better
yeah so please do look at the piece
which is installed outside and a big
applause for Sir Ernest Kapoor thank you
so much - Thank You Daniel